was sind das für zeiten wo ein gespräch
über bäume fast ein verbrechen ist
selten habe ich meine damen und herren
diese zeilen aus dem gedicht an die
nachgeborenen von bertolt brecht so oft
gehört in den letzten monaten trostlose
zeiten sind das offenbar doch neigt der
mensch nicht immer dazu die zukunft
schwärzer zu malen aus die vergangenheit
und welchen trost vermissen ja
eigentlich das diskutiere ich jetzt mit
meinem heutigen gast navid kermani ist
schriftsteller und orientalist und einer
der wichtigsten kommentatoren unserer
zeit für seine vermittlung zwischen
orient und okzident und zu seiner romane
hat ja viele hochdotierte preise
erhalten unter anderem den friedenspreis
des deutschen buchhandels ganz herzlich
willkommen ja kann man ja herr kermani
viele menschen halten die heutigen
zeiten für sehr trostlos viele glauben
sogar es geht immer schlimmer zu recht
das wissen wir noch nicht wissen wir
nicht was kommt also es gab im ersten
jahrhundert einige konstellationen
dieser gefährlichen und einige haben in
der tat auch zu großen katastrophen
geführt war vor dem ersten weltkrieg war
uns ja ähnliche dinge die auseinander
liefen und dann kam es zum großen knall
aber es gab auch eine konstellation und
ich eine frühen 80er jahre denke wo ich
war damals 15 16 17 uhr eigentlich alle
dachten jetzt kommt das zum atomkrieg
der dann doch nicht kam also die
diese angst war damals sehr sehr
beherrschend gerade bei der jungen
generation und das hatte ich dann auch
wieder aufgelöst das ist jedenfalls eine
eine gefährliche konstruktion im nahen
osten ist gehört es sowas schon da und
es gibt die kriege schon seit jahren die
wir nicht wahrgenommen haben die uns
jetzt in gestalt der flüchtlinge
vielleicht begegnen
aber ob uns wirklich die große
katastrophe woche in europa wird europa
erreicht erweist
und glauben sie dieses gefühl der
trostlosigkeit macht sich vor allem an
solchen geopolitischen spannungen heißt
oder geht es da auch um ganz andere
dinge stichwort sie haben gesagt
flüchtlingskrise die hat sich eine folge
davon ist aber auch klimawandel
digitalisierung der gesellschaft und den
eindruck hat die leute werden so unter
druck gesetzt oder gestresst aber auch
damit zu tun dass weiß ich genau so
unter stress gesetzt also ich werde mich
auch ein bisschen dagegen dass zuständig
jetzt so zu traumatisieren das ist eine
gefährliche konstellation in der
weltpolitik aber es geht in europa noch
verhältnismäßig gut wir haben keinen
krieg wir haben einigermaßen nutzungen
oder 60 staaten es gibt immer noch in
einigermaßen funktionieren
sozialausgleich wir haben unsere arbeit
haben so ein alter kann man zur
normalität alles dinge die nicht
verständlich sind immer nur ein paar
kilometer paar kilometer weiter südlich
und östlich geht schon in der ukraine
ist krieg im nahen ostens krieg in
nordafrika sind die zustände schon ganz
anders die menschen halten sondern haben
diesen alltag in weiten teilen schon
verloren also dieses dieses dieses
diesem moment das dass man sagt jetzt
ist alles ganz schrecklich
da denke ich immer dann schaut doch mal
hin wo es wirklich schrecklich ist also
dass das geht ja darum dass auch zu
verteidigen was wir noch haben und dafür
zu sorgen und dann klar wird auch
dauerhaft kann es nicht gut gehen wird
unsere frieden unserer roadshow nicht
bewahren sein wenn es in so
unmittelbarer nähe so viel gewalt krieg
ungerechtigkeit und sozialer not gibt
also dachte dass das muss das ist glaube
ich der wesentliche punkt zu begreifen
dass nicht nur die welt eine ist sondern
das war hier die mindestens die direkte
nachbarschaft uns und mittler betrifft
und dass wir nicht einfach uns da
abschotten können
also auch die ungleichheit die sozusagen
eine sprengkraft besitzt die gefährlich
werden könnte natürlich das ist ja nicht
nur krieg ist ja auch ganz normale
soziale ungleichheit wenn einen sagen
wir haben jetzt ein beispiel das kann
jetzt statistisch stimmt aber sagen wir
ein lehrer im kosovo wurde in serbien
oder auf dem balkan also wirklich wenige
kilometer von zürich entfernt so viel
verdient wie ein
ich weiß gar nicht wie das in der
schweiz heisst ein hartz iv empfänger in
deutschland
dann stimmt etwas nicht ist wenn die
ohren ändern werden wenn dann wenige
kilometer weiter ein normales gehalt
einfach nicht reicht um eine eine
wohnung zu haben oder in der familie
halbwegs zu ernähren
einigermaßen würde würde vorzuleben und
so in solchen ehe mit jahr noch so
angenähert
ein solcher wohlstand herausgestellt
wird und damit getrotzt wird und die
gehälter
teilweise ist derart explodieren das ist
etwas was auf dauer sicherlich nicht gut
gehen kann und zu mal dort wo diese
konflikte so diese gegensätze so eng
aufeinander aufeinanderprallen wir in
den europäischen grenzen s-bahn drin ist
man draußen david man entweder versuchen
müssen dafür ein ausgleich zu sorgen
oder es wird werden diese grenzen werden
gesprengt werden sie gehen ja auch dahin
wo es weh tut sie bereisen diese gebiete
ein beispiel ist ein bruch der
wirklichkeit daten sie beschrieben eine
reportage gemacht zusammen mit einem
fotografen sozusagen den
flüchtlingstreck von der anderen seite
her also von budapest nach izmir
sie beschreiben dass er nüchtern sehr
sachlich es gibt auch schöne moment in
dem buch aber es gibt auch ganz viel
trostlosigkeit ist es für sie auch so
ein moment wo sie denken jetzt kommt mal
rockig mal zusammen ihr wisst überhaupt
nicht wie es in anderen ecken der welt
aussieht dass das erlebe ich nicht nach
jeder reise das gefühl doch das
unmöglich dass ich hier
besitzt jetzt hat sich in einem
fernsehstudio oder ich war letzte woche
noch noch tschetschenien
das ist eine reportage ich bin waffeln
spiegel unterwegs für eine reportage in
osteuropa
das kommt mir natürlich sehr sehr
unwirklich vor was wir hier so tun und
erleben und mein eigenes eigene alltag
das braucht seine zeit bis man hier
wieder drin ist also dass das und dann
geht einem dieses dieses gehäuse doch
sehr oft auf den wecker das dass die
probleme die es hier gibt es gibt
gewaltige probleme in der welt die uns
auch betreffen aber sie bestehe nicht
darin dass wir jetzt also ich glaube sie
sind andere als die diejenigen die wir
meistens diskutieren
ja das ist natürlich ein beispiel dafür
also ich bin christ von der krim über
russland steht nach nach georgien eine
längere reise durch ganz europa die ich
unternehme und design folge reiben
dieser abschnitt und tschetschenien ist
eigentlich was erwartet die zukunft
vielleicht auch syrien kommt ein land
grund und boden es ist kosten wie war
die ist so zerstört wie dresden gewesen
also es war einfach die am meisten
zerstört nach un angaben der meisten
zerstörte stadt der welt es gab keinen
großen die mehr durch die bombardierung
von putin und dann sind die menschen
irgendwann und das ist auch eine bittere
erfahrung aufweisen gemacht habe gewalt
unterdrückung kann sich durchsetzen und
kann menschen das rückgrat brechen und
das ist in tschetschenien geschehen hat
einen führer eingesetzte komplett
puristisches putin armee damit ein volk
das wurden von der sowjetunion dippen
komplett vollständig deportiert worden
ist das in kriegen gemartert
geschlachtet worden ist muss jetzt egal
wo es hingeht die putin bilder
betrachten
es gibt eine stabilität für die menschen
auch dankbar sind aber ist eine
politische stabilität
es ist frieden eingekehrt in der tat
sind die menschen noch froh aber es ist
natürlich eine ordnung die weit entfernt
ist
von freiheit und das glaube ich gelungen
und selbstbestimmung und das ist
natürlich etwas was uns in vielen teil
der welt so so passieren könnte süden
läuft darauf hinaus man mit massiver
gewalt bot man den widerstand nicht nur
friedlich ist natürlich so voraussagen
und tschetschenien nicht fried nicht
aufrichtig war in grund und boden und
dann baut man auf diesen trümmern
wenn nur eine welt wie sie ihm gefällt
auf die dann natürlich nicht
funktioniert weil eben die spannung
liegt eingebaut sind und ja das problem
ist das funktioniert das ist das bittere
es funktioniert immer so funktioniert
das wenn man bereit ist genügend
genügend gewalttätig zu sein dann auf
eine weise funktioniert ist es wird
nicht ganz ruhig es gibt immer noch
terroranschläge und dies und jenes
aber es gehört in ordnung wieder ein
weil die menschen irgendwann einfach
vollkommen erschöpft sind
warum machen sie solche reisen wir sind
ja sehr erfolgreicher als romanautor sie
könnten sich auch zurückziehen und die
iren ja stunde sitzen und schöne bücher
schreiben warum begeben sie sich so an
die ränder der welt also erstens glaube
ich dass ich aber einen roman zu
schreiben würde wenn ich nicht der welt
unterwegs wäre es wenn es um liebe geht
oder um ehe geht also dass das ist der
ist immer alles in allem ist alles drin
also dass das das ist sich eine person
die das buch schreibt und selbst wenn
sie über liebe nachdenkt dann ist es ja
die person die da heißt diese reise ist
die device die bestimmte dinge erfahren
hat und auch bestimmte maßstäbe
vielleicht kennen gelernt hat von dem
was wichtig ist und was nicht so wichtig
ist also und zweitens ist es ja es ist
nach von es ist klingt das vereiteln ich
glaube ich kann das ganz gut reportage
schreiben macht das ist okay einfachen
ganz gut kann und ich glaube das ist
wenn man das kann dann soll man das tun
weil es zu wenig geschieht weil das
überlässt weil das wichtiges zu zeigen
was auf der welt geschieht und das
gelingt nicht immer
es ist ja auch so dass ich selber auch
eine sehnsucht wenn ich gucke über haben
ich lese zeitungen oder kuka zu
fernsehen und oder internet und man hat
eine meinung nach der anderen alle haben
eine meinung zu irgendwas also es gibt
kein see besteht nur noch aus meinung
das medium talkshow besteht darin dass
irgendwer hat seine meinung sagt und
wenn sie das internet aufschlagen
es ist nur meinung die zeitung haben
auch die reportagen radikal
eingeschränkt und sie haben immer neue
bilder von autoren die eigene meinung zu
irgendwas äußern von dem sie meistens
auch er keine ahnung haben und ich habe
einfach gar keine lust darauf eine
weitere meinung hinein zu speisen
sondern meine sehnsucht einfach als
jemand der diese in dieser welt ist ist
selber zu sehen was da passiert also zu
beobachten zu beschreiben
und das ist auch mein talent das ich
glaube nicht dass ich immer die klügste
meinung zu irgendwas hat und dann noch
mein talent ist er und das ist dann auch
meine aufgabe die sich aus dem talente
ergibt zu beobachten mit alt in einem
live lenzen und widersprüchen in
zwischentönen was irgendwo passiert ich
finde dass gerade wahnsinnig interessant
was sie sagen weil das ja ja sozusagen
ein plädoyer ihrerseits für die
erzählung das beschreiben und wir sagen
ja auch eigentlich ist das was unsere
zeit ausmacht man sagt ja oft man lebt
in der aktivität narration ist das
stichwort der stunde
die menschen wollen erzählungen und
jetzt haben sie aber die zeitung sind
eigentlich voll von meinungen ja das ist
eine sache also ich gar nicht dass die
leute wollen
ich weiß nicht was die leute wollen
sonst würden sie nicht wollten würden
sie ja nicht mehr einschalten oder der
im internet unterwegs da nur das medium
also eine reise zu machen jetzt mit
diesem aufwand den ich da betreibe dass
das bedarf für einen apparat das ist ja
gar nicht einfach möglich man muss es
braucht eine finanzielle mittel das sind
dinge die die organisiert werden müssen
man muss kontakte herstellen das ist ein
sehr aufwendiger prozess wenn man das
gut machen will und das bedarf auch
eines eines ist einfach eines apparats
das wäre wenn ich alleine reisen würde
ohne einfach auf die auf eigene faust
wer ist auch spannend aber ich glaube
ich würde in dieser kurzen zeit nicht so
viel einblick bekommen und natürlich
frage ich mich auch
einerseits merklich und kemal eine
reportage werden gelesen die
verkaufenden ich ganz gut aber wenn die
leute wirklich interessiert werden
warum wird er genau an diesen stellen
gespart
also in deutschland kann nichts für die
schweiz kann ich nicht genau sagen aber
es gibt in deutschland einfach immer
weniger medien die so etwas überhaupt
ermöglichen
dem platz bereit stellen die
finanziellen mittel bereitstellen für
die relativ teuren reisen und all das
und dafür gibt es alle naslang eben wenn
der auch noch seinen senf zur
allgemeinen weltlage ist so gibt ohne
dass das dass das deine los ergebnis da
wird daraus erfolgt ja man muss ich
hingehen und gucken
das haben sie das heißt es liegt
wirklich auch letztendlich auch in den
an den menschen selbst also was klicken
sie das internet an
oder schauen sie ihn auch die seite drei
oder vielleicht auch heute 15 in der
zeitung diese aber kaufen müssen und
diese zeitungen muss ich vielleicht auch
nicht an den allgemeinen trend zur
knappheit erhalten
und weil man ja vielleicht auch im
internet ein paar tagen findet aber das
sei mal dahin aber selbst das ist nicht
das auch sagen das ist das ist schon
eine entwicklung natürlich wenn es eine
endliche dass das papier ist oder das
medium an
aber es geht darum dass es ein apparat
gibt mit dokumentation mit mitreise
abteilung mit es ist ein gewaltiger
aufwand
und so wie das internet funktioniert
kann es diesen aufwand nicht nicht
liefern
das heißt man ist einzelgänger und
schafft es nicht in das heißt wir obwohl
wir so viele möglichkeiten haben
beschränken wir uns in unsere
möglichkeiten informationen und
einblicke zu bekommen
eine geschichte die sie ja eigentlich
auch erzählt haben die nicht persönlich
an sehr interessiert hat und auch mir
sehr gefallen hat ist die rede zu marion
dönhoff preis die preisverleihung hat
starke von seiner rede gehabt eine
dankesrede
und das war vor kurzem erst habe ich den
preis erhalten in dieser rede erzählen
sie eigentlich auch von einer reise sie
erzählen nämlich wie sie mit ihrer
familie in vermont gelebt haben also in
diesem jahr in die hand aber in diesen
regionen
kanada und sie fragen sich in dieser
rede die kontakt zu kommen dass das amt
gewählt wurde und sie haben einen machen
da einen wunderbaren schritt sie sagen
na ja normalerweise sprechen wie man
über den angriffen im rossfeld im bible
belt da die staaten in denen vermutlich
die waren entschieden wurden oder so
wird gesprochen aber sie habt
interessiert was war in diesen regionen
los in denen sie sich so zu hause
gefühlt haben mit diesen freundlichen
menschen
und das was sie eigentlich herausstellen
ist dass sie sagen das kann kein dunkles
amerika sein weil selbst in diesen
staaten haben zwar menschen dort
abgewählt aber sie können sich nicht
vorstellen dass diese menschen die so
weltoffen sind schlecht geworden sind
oder dass ich darin eben etwas gezeigt
haben sollte angeblich massiver wandel
dieser personen
na ja das glaube ich nicht dass menschen
sich in zwei jahren so massiv verändern
und zu mal der diese region eigentlich
demokratisches und das ist das
eigentlich ist demokratisch das ist ja
dass das merkwürdige das selbst regionen
in denen etwa der amerikanische volk
sorgen denn immer politisch war was denn
hervorgegangen ist indes woodstock lag
in denen also wirklich regionen die
jetzt gar nicht dem klischee dieses
dieses waffenstarrende jede cars
entsprechen region in dem die
gewerkschaften stark war in denen
eigentlich bin ich senders ganz große
erfolge gefeiert hat aus den euro aber
herr kommt dass diese region diesmal die
alle noch für obama gestimmt haben also
nicht per se irgendwie dunkel und böse
und wie man das gerne hätte um die welt
schon einzuteilen in gut und böse und
der inder sind böse und wir sind
natürlich immer gut denn gerade dort
sind ja auch die wahlen aus sicht der
demokraten verloren war worden wo halten
nicht demokratisches und land legt wo
die menschen eigentlich nicht unbedingt
jemanden wie trump wählen würden und ist
diesmal getan haben und da ist die frage
na ja das dass die waffenlobby schreiben
ist ja klar aber wie so kommt es dass
diese menschen dass diese wahlbezirke an
trump gefallen sind und da
hat es doch gleich weniger zu tun mit
pop sondern mit dem angebot der
liberalen gesellschaft und ich glaube
dass wir gar nicht so sehr über die über
die stärke der jenaer sprechen müssen
sondern würde ich schwäche jeder seite
und ich glaube dass die liberale
gesellschaft ist hat sich auch beim
raxit gezeigt ich glaube werden die
meisten menschen also wenn wenn wenn
wenn europa vertreten wird von einem
offen opportunistischen wirtschaft
überall ministerpräsidenten wie
premierminister david cameron
dann hat europa schwach schwache karten
das heißt wir diejenigen die für ein
offenes ohr für europa streiten
diejenigen die für die liberale
gesellschaft streiten wir sind zu
schwach ist nicht so dass die anderen so
extrem stark sind die samen in diesem
text auch was gefehlt hat zb hillary
clinton ist der sogenannte enthusiasm
faktor das hat gesagt er hat richtig
aber sie betonen dass ich ja aber nicht
gerecht da hat es heute heißt er ist ja
nicht dumm und er hat auf dem
entscheidenden punkt hingewiesen
er war aber der new york times zu
besuchen nachdem sich erinnern sie sich
und er hat gesagt also die ganz normales
umfrageinstitute haben wir alles vorher
gesagt dass clinton gewesen und es gebe
ein einziges ein einziges das
umfrageinstitut das gesagte trump
gewinnt und warum die hatten eine zieht
er jetzt nur geschafft ich noch nicht
träumen lassen aber donald trump sagte
wir hätten ein faktor einberechnet in
sogenannten enthusiasmus faktor das
heißt die mobilisierungskraft und top
sagte selbst und glaube ich vollkommen
richtig konnte meine leute mobilisieren
hillary clinton konnte es nicht deshalb
hab ich geworden das heißt wenn es ein
kandidat gewesen wäre oder eine
kandidatin die der es gelungen wäre
menschen zu begeistern dann die sie
wahrscheinlich gewonnen und das problem
ist nur mit dem status quo also mit den
immer nur weiter kann man keine menschen
begrüßt man kann menschen begeistern
wenn man für veränderung steht für für
für etwas was in die zukunft weist und
nicht immer nur für das was es schon
gibt wird das establishment und hillary
clinton stand wie keine andere
kandidatin für den status quo für das
was es gibt für diese session natürlich
wurde sie auch so produziert von traum
von der von den für den von seinen
medien aber es ist ja sie hat er dieses
schwache die zahlen diese flanke auch
gehört
weil sie wirklich für dieses
establishment stand aber commission
dilemma rhein ist haben wir am anfang
war darüber gesprochen wie trostlos ist
eigentlich unsere welt dann haben wir
darauf hingewiesen naja eigentlich gibt
es andere regionen muss sehr viel
schlechter läuft vielleicht ist es bei
uns gar nicht so trostlos gleichzeitig
kann man politisch nur punkten wenn man
veränderungen anbietet und irgendwie
sagt es wird besser oder es wird anders
aber manchmal ist es doch auch aufgabe
der politik zu sagen so schlecht ist das
gar nicht lasst uns das bewahren was sie
haben und das verteidigen was wir haben
ja auch gesagt habe ich auch natürlich
das stimmt ja auch nur dennoch glaube
ich dass wir dringend verändert und das
trinken oder eine welt in der ein europa
in dem jeden tag menschen eine grenzen
ertrinken den dessen ende dessen grenzen
krieg herrscht in europa dessen
europäische union entweder wahnsinnig
wichtiges projekt ich glaube das
wichtigste projekt der generation
unserer eltern zerfällt in dem großen
staaten aus europäischen union austreten
in europa dem es nicht gelingt eine
gemeinsame wirtschaftspolitik eine
gemeinsame flüchtlingspolitik eine
gemeinsame außenpolitik zu schaffen das
eine welt in der auch soziale gegensätze
auseinandergehen höhe stärker werden
indem immer weniger immer mehr haben und
immer mehr immer weniger haben und das
sind ja dinge die die man sich nicht
einfach abfinden sondern die ja
statistisch belegbar sind
dass das genügt einfach nur weiter so
nicht ich glaube dass wir schon auch
veränderungen brauchen aber dass die
veränderung vielleicht noch nicht
diejenigen sind die nur von der einen
seite kommen müssen sondern es gibt ja
auch andere wege dinge die menschen
unzufrieden machen etwa nehmen sie nur
die die situation an den europäischen
außengrenzen selbst derjenige der für
das recht von politischen flüchtlingen
ein steht auf politisches asyl
kann ja nicht zufrieden sei mit der
situation dass faktisch nur diejenigen
durchkommen weil wir komplett ich werde
das immer wir europäische union und die
schweiz ist keine insel aber auch wird
das verzeihen sie mir wenn wir komplett
die grenzen ab
abschotten bedeutet dass es kommen nur
diejenigen über die illegal es schaffen
und das ist kommt nie für sich stärke
diejenigen die gremien die kriminellen
überkommt das ist ja keine befriedigende
situation auch nicht für diejenigen die
die etwa für den flüchtlingsschutz
stehen das heißt grenzen müssten
natürlich auch kontrolliert werden
können und das geschieht nicht nur das
eine beispiel zu nennen dass selbst
diejenigen die vielleicht einverstanden
sind
generell darf damit dass man flüchtlinge
aufnimmt
mit der jetzigen situation die
einverstanden sein können abgesehen
davon natürlich dass diese zeitweise
öffnung der grenzen ja auch schon wieder
längst vorbei ist und die station etwa
in der türkei auf der griechischen insel
vollkommen trostlos ist aber ist eine
schwierigkeit nicht wenn ihr beim
stichwort trostlosigkeit bleiben dass
die bewertung der trostlosigkeit die
frage was eigentlich los ist an der
situation so unglaublich
unterschiedlichen sich disparat ausfällt
also es gibt bestimmt diejenigen die der
meinung sind genauso wie es gesagt haben
die trostlosigkeit besteht darin dass
wir zb keine globale idee davon haben
wie integrationen umgehen wollen oder
wie wir ungleichheit bekämpfen wollen
aber andere finden meine trostlose
situation ist diejenige dass mein gehalt
nicht steigt dass hier so viele fremde
rumlaufen es gibt ja auch diese
situation wenn man guckt trostlosigkeit
des mittelstandes die vielen
diskussionen die es gegeben habe denken
sie beispielsweise an das wunderbare
buch ich gerne raus und die die er über
er beschreibt das ja wie die menschen in
frankreich plötzlich marine le pen
wählen die vorher natürlich keiner weise
sozialistisch unterwegs waren und wie da
die leute plötzlich den eindruck haben
auf nicht guckt hier keiner
ja aber ich glaube dass man viele dieser
menschen erreichen kann das ist nicht so
ist dass das wenn es ist ja das
verrückte ist dass aber medica viele
derjenigen die alten nicht sagen wir für
eines senders in den vorwahlen gestimmt
haben kann sich vorab entschieden haben
nur hauptsache auf veränderungen
hauptsache eine veränderung und ich
glaube ich kenne sie aus eigener hand
schauen würde ich nicht bin ja auch als
reporter oft und gegenden wo man nicht
meiner meinung ist das ist ja etwas was
ich das ganz gut dass du mein beruf dazu
und dann besuche ich veranstaltung der
afg in deutschland oder bin in kreisen
in rust unterwegs
die wo ich vielleicht andere meinungen
bin in vielen dingen und dennoch es ist
wichtig dass kennenzulernen zu erfahren
und ins gespräch zu kommen und ich
glaube das ist auch wichtig für menschen
an
das ist eine begegnung sein kann die ich
glaube sehr große skepsis ist was die
führer dieser partei betrifft also das
sind zum teil
ich kenne sie ja nicht nur deshalb will
ich kein moralisches urteil fällen aber
das ist mir schon etwas eher respekt
aber ich weiß aus eigener erfahrung aus
eigener anschauung
das ist sehr oft möglich ist im gedenken
gespräch wenn man menschen
gegenübersteht weil die menschen in den
seltenen fällen von allem komplett immer
100 prozent überzeugt sondern auch in
ihrem alltag ambivalenzen sehen manchmal
unsicherheiten haben nicht genau wissen
oder wie das zu bewerten dass und wie
man das selber auch hat so gibt und sagt
man weiß ja auch nicht genau wie es
weitergehen könnte
entsteht sofort ein gespräch und ich
glaube das ist die aufgabe auch in den
politischen diskurs dass man nicht dass
man natürlich die die auseinandersetzung
sucht oder auch noch mal dazu heißt auch
die die persönliche begegnung und zwar
nicht nur auf der ebene von
repräsentanten sondern auch im
persönlichen alltag ist das so
vielleicht eine grundhaltung von ihnen
herr kermani
grundsätzlich war mit der klugheit der
menschen zu rechnen wird er ich will ja
nicht sagen klugheit aber auch durchaus
bei der gute der menschen also dass der
mensch gut ist im herzen also dass man
menschen erreichen kann und dass man
zugleich natürlich fehlbar und und ein
ängstliches wesen ist aber dass man also
die die anzahl der wirklich bösen
menschen die ich so weit reisen begegnen
habe begegnet bin die ist sehr sehr
gering
diebe anzahl der unsichere menschen ist
sehr groß und ich glaube das ist etwas
wo man als unsicherheit der wächst auch
natürlich viele probleme aber man wenn
man ich bin ja auch oft unsicher bin ja
auch gar nicht in allem sicher und das
geht ja darum ist ja erst mal zuzuhören
und zu schauen was eigentlich
allein schon dass das haben wir das
problem dass durch diese entwicklung der
diese parallele öffentlichkeiten das ist
das merken wir doch gerade in amerika
ganz stark dass bestimmte inhalte ein
großteil der menschen überhaupt nicht
mehr erreichen dass das thema optik
medien nicht mehr wahrnehmen die datei
konsumiert und das ist mal bis es gibt
sozusagen mein mann ist in diesem sender
einen eigenen blase die werte mit immer
resistent dagegen jeder an jeder hat
eine andere informationen und alles was
kommt bestätigt das eigene weltbild das
ist nicht übertragbar denn so und das
ist bei liberalen überall öffentlichkeit
letztendlich nicht so viel anders und
ich glaube dass du dich stoßen und vor
allem einfach mal zu erfahren wie kommt
jemand zu seiner weltsicht wie denkt der
wie nimmt er das war das sind die gründe
dafür dass er das so sieht wie er es
sieht ist jedenfalls in teilen die
aufgabe die ich dich hab ich habe sich
ihre rede gelesen habe und sie über
diesen enthusiasmus facto nachdenken und
eben darüber dass wir unbedingt dafür
sorgen müssen dass ihr begeistern können
mit einer alternativen idee mit einer
utopie vielleicht habe ich an ihr
kinderbuch denken müssen das am 30
januar in einer neuen auflage erscheint
in einer überarbeiteten version neu
dabei und hause ein wohn eine wunderbare
geschichte die mir außerordentlich gut
gefällt und was mir daran so gut gefällt
ist dass dieses kleine mädchen die aida
die ja immer als knirps bezeichnet wird
ist klein geht im kindergarten hat
schwierigkeiten freunde zu finden würde
auch gerne durch den eigelstein ziehen
dieses quartier in köln in dem sie auch
leben und findet niemanden der damit
kommt und dann wird sie wütend fährt weg
mit dem fahrrad fällt hin schlägt sich
das knie blutig und dann passiert etwas
sehr überraschend dass es kommt nämlich
in bar und ein hase und was werden ihre
freunde und warum ich an dieses buch
denken musste bei der lektüre rede ist
das hier eine ganz überraschende lösung
die lösung sein wird es ist eigentlich
etwas was man überhaupt nicht erwartet
man erwartet dass dieses kind freunde
findet wie hat andere kinder freunde
finden und ich habe mich gefragt ist das
vielleicht das problem haben wir kein
bild von bernd haase
4 unsere gesellschaft andere idee also
ich glaube dass wir jedenfalls mit dem
unerwarteten rechnen müssen dieses
tropische wenn man dieses utopisch
element aus der politik raus nimmt man
immer nur mit dem status quo rechnet mit
kleinen städten politik muss natürlich
in kleinen schritten fort waren das ist
ihre aufgabe
ohne dieses diesen blick auch in zukunft
von der man nicht genau weiß ob es
gelingt dann wären die großen dinge
dieser welt nie passiert es hätte nie
eine europäische union gegeben hätte nie
einen wirklichen frieden in europa
gegeben
das ist ja auch etwas was was man
heutzutage vergisst also wie die wie
schwierig das war sie dass das ist doch
als ich aufgewachsen bin in meiner zeit
der schüleraustausch in frankreich als
deutsche schüler
da hatte ich erst mal den vorteil weil
es für die damals waren der 18 jahren
schwierig war in frankreich eltern zu
finden die ein deutsches kind aufnehmen
zu hause einfach nicht die nicht gehen
weil das neu wird das war den
kriegsgegner und so weiter das ist ja
nicht lange her und jetzt haben wir das
geschafft in europa und das wenn man
etwa die gründungsgeschichte der
europäischen union betrachtet auch schon
vor dem krieg 19 jahrhundert oder auch
jean monnet oder schumann
das waren und pisten die haben nicht
einfach nur kohle und stahl zusammen
gesetzt sondern die haben nur an der
schriften liest die haben nichts
geringeres als die rotierende
gerechteren welt vor augen gehabt und
das war ihr antrieb und ich glaube schon
dass man diesen blick in die zukunft wie
wenn man in 20 30 40 jahren leben
braucht damit man auch die kleinen
schritte überzeugen gehen keiner noch
einen kompass hat weil sonst das
beobachte ich in der politik und in der
deutschen politik man diesen diesen
kompass nicht hat dann geht man mit dem
wind dann geht man einmal die richtung
oder man in jede richtung aber es ist
kein es ist nichts was wir dass menschen
leiten oder begeistern kann und das ist
jetzt vielleicht eine viel zu schwierige
frage woher könnten wir den utopien
heute generieren ist ja eigentlich das
silicon valley hat man den eindruck dass
den takt vorgibt mit kopien bezüglich
verschmelzung von mensch und maschine
oder langlebigkeit bis hin zur
unsterblichkeit das sind die utopie oder
auch die fantasien die menschen heute
beschäftigen die wir diskutieren also
mir würde es schon genügen und das ist
jetzt vielleicht etwas weniger
spektakulär als die erfindung von den
robotern oder irgendwas wenn es gelingt
in diesem europa das dem so viele
verschiedene menschen auf engstem raum
zusammenleben und zwar nicht nur jetzt
auf die als nation bezogen sondern
innerhalb der völker- dass wir diese
diese buntheit diese vielfältigkeit der
kompliziert und schwierig ist die
konflikte das merken wir gerade wenn es
gelingt sie einigermaßen friedlich zu
regeln
das heißt dass wir das ist uns gelingt
diesen ausgleich zu schaffen zwischen
vielfalt zwischen dem was dass kultur
nicht mehr so geschlossen sind was sie
übrigens auch eigentlich nie waren und
dann eigentlich erst durch die beiden
weltkriege geworden sind vor den beiden
weltkriegen machen sie genau so viel
nicht geschlossen oder homogen und nun
hat ja auch das genau unter anderem zu
diesen beiden weltkriegen geführt wenn
man etwa auf dem balkan schaut oder auch
auf deutschland aber das ist gelingt
wirklich das ist ja der kern eine
nichteuropäische idee der kern
europäischen idee ist ja nicht der
frieden und dann ist die idee ist die
gleichheit die freiheit und die
brüderlichkeit das sind ist erklären
jetzt europa geführt
der frieden wo sozusagen nur nach den
beiden weltkriegen zudem mittelwald
gesehen so nach frieden da war europa
verwirklichen über einen kern ist der
kern europäischen idee ist nichts
anderes als die werte der aufklärung und
dass die sind glaube ich relevanter ich
bin ja auf den schuhen unterwegs und das
schaue ich mich in die klar in den
klassen ich weiß nicht wie es in der
schweiz ist aber heutzutage auch auf
jedem gymnasium das ist ja nicht mehr so
dass die ausnahme kinder auf den
hauptschulen sind die deutschen sind in
dem gymnasium weg er ist vollkommen
gemischt wenn sie eine oberstufe gehen
und ich blicke mich und ich schaue auf
die klassen und sage also entschuldigen
europa der vaterländer wollt ihr das
wirklich haben dann wird auch der vater
von dem neben der jetzt nicht mehr dazu
also müssen wir doch einen anderen
begriff von nation von heimat von von
ein staatsvolk finden als das was unsere
eltern uns erzählt haben
glauben sie europa könnte scheitern ja
das ist ja dabei das zu scheitern also
ich das ist nicht nur weit entfernt also
wenn ganz konkret wenn in holland und
frankreich
die rechtspopulisten wirklich die wahl
gewinnen sollten das ist nicht
wahrscheinlich ist aber möglich ist dann
ist europa glaube ich ziemlich nah dran
am scheitern also dann haben sie eine
konstellation mit pole mit ungarn mit
staaten in osteuropa mit england das
austritt mit trump mit putin der zerrt
und unterminiert also ich glaube der
unternehmer europas ist jedenfalls der
europäischen union ist näher als man das
meint aber er ist natürlich noch zu
verhindern
etwas was in diesem buch auch wichtig
ist so fasst ihm leid motiv ist dass der
vater dieses kleinen mädchens immer
wieder sagt du musst daran glauben das
ist eigentlich wieder leitsatz und in
diesem zusammenhang ist mir barack obama
in den sinn gekommen der in seiner
letzten rede vor seiner verabschiedung
in chicago noch einmal dieses daran
glauben in szene gesetzt hat und
appelliert hat und ich möchte mit ihnen
diese stelle ganz kurz angucken
[Musik]
er appelliert daran dass man daran
glauben sollte dass man etwas verändern
kann
er ist das gefällt nicht so gut auch
amerika damit sind die ja auch
aufgewachsen ich weiß nicht wie es bei
jedem aber ich bin hier aufgewachsen mit
dieser folkmusik bob de jong rockmusik
das war ja das waren ja eigentlich die
britischen werte vielmehr als kantor
botes kühe den aufgewachsen sind diese
amerikanischen populärkultur und das war
immer diese diese diese freiheits
partners dem uramerikanisch ist und der
uns natürlich irgendwie auch geprägt hat
oder nicht jedenfalls und das ist etwas
was auch was ganz großartig ist also bei
allem schattenseiten natürlich auch
amerikas
aber diesen moment auch dann an etwas zu
glauben also man kann ja nur über sich
selbst hinauswachsen wenn man nach oben
schaut und nicht wenn man ständig auf
dem boden schaut und ich glaube das ist
uns durch den pragmatismus der letzten
jahre kann das wie gesagt nicht für die
schweiz genommen einschätzen aber
jedenfalls in vielen ländern europas mit
dem auch politiker generation die auch
ein ausdruck ist eine in der bevölkerung
an das allgemeine allgemein stimmung das
ist nicht die erste politikerin schuld
das sind ja auch die politiker sind
letztendlich nichts anderes als die
repräsentanten muss er weise dessen was
auch ein stimmung im volk ist und die
nehme ich schon sehr verzagt war
und diejenigen werden ja belächelt die
noch etwas nicht richtig denken eine
gerechtere welt räumen die sagen es ist
schwer natürlich mit alkohol probleme
der welt in den griff zu bekommen
aber wenn man sich aber die frage stellt
wie sie denn in den griff zu bekommen
sie wären dann wird beim nächsten
vorkommnis ist arizona alternativ
prinzip dieses klima bringt so ist
wirklich der fehler auch nach 89 also
dieses denken jetzt hat er hat die
liberale gesellschaft triumphiert jetzt
haben wir es geschafft jetzt ist das war
ein fataler fehler weil natürlich
probleme auch nach dem untergang der
sowjetunion nicht nur weitere gegangen
sind sie noch nicht verschärft haben nur
verdeckt worden sind von dem
triumphalismus der sich dem westen dort
gemacht hat haben sie dieses buch
eigentlich damals für ihre kinder
geschrieben weil das spielt ja in dem
quartier heute noch leben absolut das
war das gilt es doch das buch das ich
vor der tochter erzählt habe sozusagen
und jahrzehnt ihre kinder jetzt also die
ältere tochter ist jetzt 18 das war
diejenige die es damals
der ist damals erzählt hat und die
jüngere tochter ist neun und haben sie
den eindruck dieses man sollte daran
glauben haben es irgendwie avater jan
kinder mit geben können
das müssen sie meine kinder fragen aber
was ich wahrnehme das ist vielleicht
sogar wichtiger oder in was relevant ist
dass ich in letzter zeit in jüngster
zeit jedenfalls in deutschland bei den
jungen menschen bei den schülern wo ich
nicht treffe wirklich die politisierung
erlebt habe und eingeschritten wirklich
wachsende sagen euch mal wirklich viele
jahre fand man in schulen gehen oder die
schüler ein
die lehrer auch in dem ziemlich
desinteressiert vorkamen und ich merke
jetzt kommen zu den veranstaltungen
immer mehr junge menschen es und zwar
wurde lesung als auch zu den sagen die
kritischen veranstaltung ist in den
schulen werde ich da hingehe ist ist
wirklich ist großes interesse die leute
sind total engagiert
diese flüchtlingswelle in deutschland
hat gerade die jungen menschen wirklich
durchgerüttelt und auch empathische
gemacht und interessiert für die
weltpolitik wo er sich einfach fragen wo
kommt der her wieso kommen die und es
sind begegnungen entstanden
in vielen schulen in deutschland sind
irgendwie auch flüchtlinge die
integriert werden müssen und dann stehen
begegnungen und es gibt mir schon
hoffnung also dass das das dass diese
jungen menschen diesen verzweiflungs
druck den wir vielleicht nicht mehr
hatten und deshalb dinge aus der hand
geben weil wir nicht bekämpfen weil wir
denken das wird schon laufen
ich glaube dass viele jungen menschen
spüren dass wenn man nicht aufpasst dass
diese welt in der sie aufgewachsen sind
nicht mehr so bleiben wird sprechen über
ein anderes moment das vielleicht auch
trost spenden könnte oder veränderungen
utopie im leben rein wird nämlich die
liebe
das ist auch ein thema mit dem sie sich
in vielen ihren büchern
auseinandersetzen
der neueste roman sozusagen paris widmet
sich auch dem thema liebe nun muss man
allerdings sagen hier ist die liebe ja
auch ein stück weit schon ein bisschen
desillusioniert und man fragt sich so
ein bisschen passiert das eigentlich mit
jeder gebe dass irgendwann aus dieser
verliebtheit keine langweilige jetzt ja
dass die verliebtheit nicht anhält das
passiert wurde den allermeisten fällen
dass wir auch komisch wir nicht also mit
diesem herzklopfen
das wäre auch ziemlich echt nicht so gut
nur dass über jahrzehnte verstetigen sie
nach schäden
ja aber es gibt auch im alltag es gibt
dinge wo liebe anstrengend wird es gibt
krankheiten es gibt dann dass das
physische altern dass man hier niemals
über eignet er sich sondern immer im
gesicht des partner so sieht und das
natürlich auch etwas auslöst also das
ist glaube ich normal dass das dass das
kind doch glaube ich kann nicht anders
sein dass die verliebtheit übergehen
muss etwas anderes ruhigeres stetiges
und das dann gelingt oder nicht das kann
man im zwischen der verliebtheit selten
voraussagen ob das gelingen wird weil
das einfach ganz andere bedingungen sind
in denen sich liebe dann behaupten wird
oder nicht
es ist ja ein stück weit auch so dass
sie einen mit einem kunstgriff eine
andere figur noch ein ziel und das
kommen will und wo aber der lektor mich
sicher dann auch ein und der sagt moment
maria das ist auch gar nicht schlechter
sondern das ist eigentlich der kern der
liebe der kern der liebe ist nicht die
verliebtheit sei der kerner liebe ist
gerade das zueinander schauen beisteuern
und meine anderen kindern
zuverlässigkeit beisteuern dass man da
ist in der not dass man dass man gerade
diese dinge die vielleicht nicht so sexy
sind aber die dass man sich
verlässlichkeit die gemeinsame sich
einig seine vielen dingen etwas die
kinder betrifft das machen was anderes
vielleicht sogar über des eigenen den
eigenen spaß oder das eigene vergnügen
oder die eigene selbstverwirklichung
stellt aus sicht des lektors ist das hat
er sein wert so sicht der protagonisten
vielleicht nicht unbedingt genau das ist
ein bisschen unklar weil man die
protagonisten eine nacht zusammen
verbringen und eigentlich nur reden aber
in dieser nacht ja immer auch damit
gespielt wird dass die verliebtheit
wieder auf keinen könnte und was auf den
jeden etwas glitzerndes schillerndes
entstehen könnte ja aber die literatur
bedeutet niemals die erfüllung sondern
immer nur die sehnsucht nach etwas so
dass die erfüllung ist die literatur
sehr uninteressant weil sie da
eigentlich selten worte findet sondern
literatur im wesentlichen wenn das nicht
zu sehr pauschal ihren
steht ihr aus diesem moment das ist
etwas anderes gäbe aber es gibt es nicht
eigentlich auch nicht nutzen ja
eigentlich eigentlich man aufwächst also
wenn ein kind aufwächst besteht er sein
leben aus lauter enttäuschung ist wächst
auf eine geborgenheit und irgendwann sei
es durch die drei monats koliken oder
sei es und das allein gelassen wird oder
weil es jetzt die erste nach
durchschlafen sollen die eltern gebannt
vor der tür war das kind schreien lassen
damit es endlich mal ein schläfchen
momente auch der enttäuschung
bis jetzt war immer alles machen sich
immer alle gekümmert oder das war immer
geborgenheit da und nähe und
zärtlichkeit und plötzlich ist alles
nicht mehr da das heißt aber im book ins
bewusstsein dringt sich ein das gab es
das sieht man sich dass es wieder so
kommt das ist eigentlich ein antrieb
überhaupt menschlichen strebens wieder
zurück zu kommen oder wieder dieses die
etwas was man kennt war von dem man
glaubt das ist da ist zu erreichen wäre
wenn wir das nicht kennen würden wenn
wir nicht durch die verlebt hat etwa das
glück der liebe kennenlernen würden dann
würden wir uns nicht sehen danach das
finde ich sehr interessant vorhin haben
sie aber noch hat das gesagt habe ich
auch hängen geblieben wenn ich gesagt
ein stückweit beschreibt die literatur
nie die erfüllung sozusagen sondern
immer nur die sehnsucht danach warum
kann den literatur trösten das kann sie
ja durchaus wenn man nicht allein ist
weil man so quasi merkt da gibt es noch
andere die haben das gleiche problem
50.000 jahren das ist eine das macht sie
groß und klein sie macht groß war oder
sie macht klein weiß ich gemerkt dass
was man das war ein selbst so absolut
brennend ist und überwältigendes und
mein schmerz meinen kummer mein
verzweiflung
das ist das ist so ist der
vogelperspektive er so gewöhnlich
selbst das was einem individuell als das
allergrößte erscheint ist mit dem blick
der literaturgeschichte die 5000 jahren
ist das relativ klein das ist einfach
nur einer von soviel beispiel und
zugleich macht sie große literatur weil
unsere kleinen probleme durch die
literatur durch die vergrößerung die
literatur erzeugt plötzlich auch als
allgemeingültige schein es gibt nicht
mehr nur so die kleinen probleme bei
einer frau oder freundin mal in meinem
wurde oder bei den eltern sondern in
diesem konflikt zwischen dem vater und
dem sohn ist sind alle konflikte
zwischen vätern und söhnen drin in dem
kleinen ist alles drin
und das machen sie auch immer
transparent in ihrem schreiben dass sie
sagen es ist verweben das schreiben
sozusagen immer schon mit den
geschichten die da waren in große liebe
war dass die mystische literatur
persische liebesmüh stick beispielsweise
und in diesem roman ist das anknüpfen an
vielen französischen autorin fuß
flaubert und so weiter
und sie sagen eigentlich auch im grunde
genommen ist alle literatur ein stück
weit ein plagiat weil man sich ja immer
wieder bezieht auf die texte die es
schon gibt aber das ist nichts negatives
sondern vielleicht ist es einfach sagen
wir die erzählung der menschheit die
weinglas ich spenden sie haben ja
berechtigt so zitiert bricht sich der
größte räuber von ein großartiger ort
als literat ein krimineller was ja dass
da geklaut und und sich zu eigen gemacht
hat und natürlich großartig dabei aber
in der tat ich glaube dass man an die
tour auch an den anteil des
autobiografischen notorisch überschätzt
denn alle teil von lektüren haben roman
notorisch unterschätzt jeder hat von
herzhafte literatur besteht zu einem
sehr viel größeren anteil als man oft
meint ausgelesenen bücher nahost lektüre
fahren jetzt entsteht daraus dass man
andere bücher liest und sie etwas
auslösen dass man das eigene erlebte
einordnet vor diesem kanon sieht
bewertet und das einzige derartige
unterschiede nicht in diesen beiden
beiden büchern mache nicht in allen
büchern ist der das ich diese sich diese
lektüre erfahrung expliziert machen
prinzip mache ich habe sozusagen nicht
ich mache ein roman ohne vierte wand und
und/oder spreche beiseite wie im theater
also ich bin für das auf ein romane
sogar ich spreche ich zu den zuschauern
es sind ja dinge die seit jeher also
denken sie nur an die uhr situation der
literatur ist erzählen aber erzählen
erzählt mal und zugleich hat man den
blick wenn jemand nur die raum betritt
und zählt kurz noch mal schnell nach was
da bis jetzt passiert ist oder wann
sieht man schläft ein also schlecht
marinaden oder macht sich lustig über
denen zugleich oder es ist ein tag an
dem dies und jenes in der welt passiert
ja ja und man nimmt es auf und da machen
sie ja nochmal was ganz unglaublich
lustiges sie sprechen nämlich dauern das
publikum auch an auch das ist ein
stilmittel das man ein stück weit schon
von anderen autoren kennt aber sie
machen es irgendwie noch einmal sich
leider unglaublich charmanten art und
weil das auch in diesem buch sich und
rechner immer wieder mit den kindern ja
aber ich würde es nicht machen wenn es
nicht für viele autos vor mir schon
gemacht hätten
na ja das ist sie da ihren bescheiden in
einer rede seine position vor
dann nehmen sie nur das wort roman
strenger ein beispiel zu nennen das ist
ein wunderbares wort aber es ist so
wunderbar ist das hätte selber finden
konnte das ist natürlich von jean paul
und in dem ich das wort aufnehmen
für den als begriff für die der erzähler
es ist ja auch ein signal dass ich mich
genau diese tradition hinein stelle auch
wenn ich diesen roman jean-paul nicht
erwähnen
das heißt alle dass all die mittel die
es da gibt
ich glaube eigentlich sogar würde sogar
behaupten dass die modernen literatur in
ihren wesentlichen mittel mit kafka
beckett joyce zu ende ist dass wir
seither mittel neu in neue konstellation
weiter führen aber in dem es nichts
neues erschaffen in diesem genre des
romans und das ist doch überhaupt nicht
schlimm das ist ja völlig normal es gibt
in der klassische musik auch sein kann
die kirche besten phasen sind nicht die
phasen in denen etwas komplett neues
entstanden ist und wo man mit den
mitteln dies gab konsolidieren was man
geschaffen und das sind keine schlechten
was nehmen sie nur die zeit von mahle
[Musik]
und hatte alles was was mahler aufnimmt
gab es falsche nur es gab kein mal ein
schönes bild ein anderes moment des
trostes über das hier noch sprechen
können und von dem ich denke das ist ihr
werk aus unglaublich stark ausmacht ist
die frage des glaubens und der religion
und wenn wir die bibel beispielsweise
lesen bei paulus ist gott der tröster
das ist eigentlich die trost figur
überhaupt glauben sie glaube kaum
trösten oder verständliches moment ja
ich hoffe dass glaube du wirst oder so
dass das oder den natürlich kein trost
und glaube auch gar nicht recht
vorstellen denn also gerade jetzt um
zurückzukommen auf die auf den reisenden
also ich flehe das regelrecht ab wenn
ich die zustände der welt sehe in einer
wirklich so ist das überhaupt und ist
einfach menschen gibt die trostlos leben
und ich finde es moralisch nicht
statthaft über eine eigene station das
ist in ordnung also ich kann mich nicht
beklagen und hätte für viele momente das
trost ist nur der welt als solche keine
gerechtigkeit sagte attestieren dass das
mag ich nicht weil ich einfach zu viele
menschen abgesehen habe die grundlos
ungerecht leiden und zwar in der weise
bleiben die uns unvorstellbar erscheint
und da gibt es kein trost und nicht kann
es nur geben wenn es für alle gibt
introns der nur für einige menschen in
westeuropa da wäre kein trost dass werde
das würde ja nur denn das ist das
unglück der anderen noch einmal steigern
weil wir es genießen dürfen die anderen
nicht
das heißt streng genommen und das hat
viel mit den erfahrungen zu tun die ich
so gesehen aber die könnte man
wahrscheinlich hier auf andere weise
genauso machen wenn man sagen wir eine
krebsstation arbeitet oder mit menschen
zusammen
ist in erhältlich wer richtig liegt
sozusagen diese diese welt zu
beschönigen
zu sagen es ist schon in ordnung oder
das wird schon besser werden nein das
wird nicht besser werden in dem sinne
ist es nicht besser geworden
die welt ist wie sie ist und es war auch
nicht für besser als heute sondern der
zoos denn es gibt für mich jedenfalls
persönlich der leitet sich aus einem
moment ab dass es dinge gibt die nicht
wirklich die nicht sozusagen real sind
oder die nicht realistisch sind und
dennoch gelingen können dass menschen
frieden finden können
der eigentlich gar nicht möglich scheint
der gar nicht gar nicht denkbar so ist
angesichts der umstände und das kann man
jetzt religiös deuten im sinne eines des
religiösen friedens
aber man kann es auch säkulare deuten in
dem es in dem menschen eine innere ruhe
inneren frieden noch eine kraft zur lebe
finden die über das übliche maß
hinausgeht und ist dennoch möglich ist
obwohl es eigentlich gar nicht möglich
sein kann und dafür gibt es ja beispiele
von menschen die ohne möglich ist tun
und es gelingt ihm
ich finde eigentlich ist der titel
dieses buches ungläubiges staunen über
das christentum ein buch das vor zwei
jahren glaube ich erschienen ist finde
ich das ja sehr schön ein dass sie sagen
es geht eigentlich um dieses um dieses
staunen um dieses rechnen eben oder
dieses hoffen auf das andere vielleicht
auch wieder ein stück weit auch auf das
utopische und sie versuchen auch zu
zeigen in diesem buch das das woran sich
das festmacht bei ihnen zumindest auch
diese auseinandersetzung mit glaube mit
spiritualität ich sehr stark auch an
einer sinnlichkeit fest macht und sie
sagen das gefällt mir sehr gut man muss
die erfahrung machen dass man
überwältigt wird und zwar nicht dass man
etwas neues begreift sondern dass man
sinnlich überwältigt wird was passiert
in diesem moment das überwältigt werden
bitte hier der mensch hoffentlich
nachvollziehen wie der mensch hat ja
hoffentlich erfahrungen mit den
überwältigt wird also
die nächstliegende erfahrung ist
natürlich sex also wenn sie mit einem
menschen unter frau oder den mann
schlafen und verzückt sind dann sind sie
bewältigt und es ist etwas das ihr
verstand außer kraft setzt und sie
verlieren sich
sie gehen über ihr eigenes ich hinaus
und vereinigen sich mit ihrem partner
oder ihre partner sind und das ist ja
etwas was jeden menschen zugänglich ist
aber im prinzip oder auch erfahrungen
der naturschönheit also fuchs hat in der
schweiz konnte ich einiges auflisten was
ich da an eine bewältigen überwältigt
bewältigen muss momenten hatte also man
wird herausgetragen sich selbst und es
ist ja nicht so ein stein beschreibt das
ja auch die gläubigkeit von einstein
macht sich fest am himmel ja natürlich
es ist und das ist etwas wo es auch gar
keinen gott für überhaupt sondern das
sind es ist eine immanente zur
transzendenz und nicht
und sie vermittelt sich natürlich kann
sich nur sinnlich vermitteln nicht über
den kopf und nicht über den verstand
selbst bei einem gedicht sie ist es
nicht die bedeutung die hier sagen wir
die reale bedeutung die man jetzt bei
wikipedia aufzählen könnte sondern jetzt
ist die die form der wird die sich
bestimmte konstellation die diesen
schmerz oder dieses glück erzeugt ist
eine sinnliche erfahrung und ich das ist
etwas der verstand jetzt an einer muss
auch einsetzen dann wird sie einordnen
will er wissen was ist da passiert
aber ohne diese erfahrung diese
erfahrungen hätte der verstand wenig zu
tun
ich frage mich zuweilen ob das was ich
mit trostlosigkeit gemeint habe am
anfang nicht auch etwas damit zu tun hat
mit dieser stück weit vielleicht angst
in unserer zeit sich diesem
überwältigenden anheim zu geben damit
meine ich sie haben selber gesagt sex
kann sowas sein wie eine erfahrung der
kompletten entäußerung aber auch glaube
kaum dass sein der glaube an gott oder
was überwältigt werden in einem natur
moment aber diese momente glaube ich
schon wie ein stück weiter auch reine
uns zu gern im griff haben wollen ja
aber es gibt ja auch politischen
erfahrungen dem zwanzigsten jahrhundert
wo auch formen der entgrenzung der
festlich und gab die sehr gefährlich
waren masse ist ja auch etwas roman
kennt grenzen kann hysterie hysterie und
natürlich gerade in deutschland gibt es
berechtigterweise ein vorbehalt gegen
diese art von erfahrung das könnte es
ist nicht nur verständlich sind auch
richtig
also das ist ja etwas sehr sehr
ambivalentes und es kann auch sehr
gefährlich sein
in dem augenblick wo eine masse hinzu
kommt wo man das zeigen jetzt hat man
sich hier nicht an einem einzelnen
menschen lebt durch die liebe durch
begeisterung sondern in einer andern im
kollektiv wird auch zu einer gefahr für
andere content für andere menschen
also das ist ja auch die faszination von
diesen organisationen deswegen auch
etwas erzeugen was was subjektiv extrem
faszinierend ist noch glück bereitet
aber natürlich für die außenwelt als als
sehr brutal darstellt ich frage mich
zuweilen neben auch ob vielleicht unsere
skepsis oder unsere angst oder wasser
haben unsere die angst von gewissen
menschen beispielsweise gegen menschen
mit migrationshintergrund die sehr
gläubig sind ob die nicht daher rührt
dass wir irgendwie auch denken das ist
uns so fremd weil ihr selber so fern
sind von einer tiefen frömmigkeit und ob
nicht dass auch ein moment sein könnte
wo wir selber merken die werden
konfrontiert mit einer eigenen sehnsucht
letztendlich also ich weiß nicht ob sie
jetzt da muss man doch das schreiben
wenn sie jetzt auf diese neue
religiosität anspielen der jungen
menschen die zum teil dann auch
gewalttätig werden nein ich möchte das
noch gar nicht mit gewalt in verbindung
bringen das wäre ja gerade glaube ich
die gefahr dass man dann darf kurz aber
ist es war einfach so ich sehe da keine
tiefe religiosität ist im menschen und
nach allem was wir wissen
die eine null kenntnissen religion haben
die ihr leben lang religiös waren und
durch irgendeinen weg muss erlebnis und
durch die gruppendynamik sich ein paar
dinge angeeignet haben aber mit sehr
sehr wenig kenntnis von dem was religion
ausmacht und ja nicht politisch groß
geworden sind also dass das hat mit mit
mit religiosität in einem volksfest in
der volksfrömmigkeit dem sie nach einer
förmlichkeit eines gelebten glaubens
wenig zu tun
natürlich ist es so dass migranten oder
einwanderer und ich nur aus der türkei
oder so auch süditalien in der welt
gekommen sind an den gesellschaften
kommen sind die relativ weit weg und
säkularisiert hatten und dieser glaube
oft auch wenn sie an 68 als irgendwie
anstößig wahrgenommen worden ist und man
hat gerade das christentum entsorgt und
kommen dann schon wieder leute mit einer
religion und mit auch und das ist ja
nicht um religion das ist ja auch
bestimmte werte es ist die
rollenaufteilung von mann und frau ist
im bestimmte autoritäts muss da es ist
die art und weise das niederknien ist
also niederknien ist etwas ganz
schreckliches für den modernen menschen
und plötzlich kommen da menschen das
müssten ja gar nicht die betende muslime
seien firma christ aus süditalien der
der knete ist etwas was was editiert
diesem moment dass man sie nicht wissen
ein fängt man sich nieder wirft in der
moschee oder betende muslime und dass
das editiert und das kann ich auch
nachvollziehen aber
also für jemanden der natürlich viel auf
reisen ist ist der meditation hat das
produkt ist aber dass erkennbar macht
was bin ich nicht selbst man lernt sich
selbst erkennen indem man auf anderes
stößt man anders beobachtet in dem man
sich unterscheidet untersucht werden
wenn ich das sehe ist jede irritation
aber ich selbst auch egal wo ich bin
würde davor nicht zurückschrecken
menschen zu sehen die ganz anderes leben
wollen sondern findet das eigentlich
erst mal interessant und neugierig sie
stehen ja ein stück weit auch für eine
sichtweise die immer dafür gekämpft hat
eben sehr differenziert zb auf den islam
zu blicken und nicht zu pauschalisieren
und genau zu schauen welche tendenzen
haben wirklich etwas zu tun mit dieser
religion und welche tendenzen haben zu
tun wie sie sagen die politische
unterdrückung und ausgrenzung zum
beispiel sie haben zb 2015 eine rede
gehalten nach den anschlägen in paris
und an die muslime appelliert in
deutschland zum beispiel den rechtsstaat
zu respektieren und für freiheit
einzutreten habe den eindruck sie werden
gehört ich kann mich jetzt natürlich
nicht sagen also ich das ist sehr schwer
für mich zu ermitteln ich habe keine
empirisch das meinungsforschungsinstitut
in der hauptstadt zu hören vielleicht
auch nicht das ist also also dadurch
dass ich nicht im netz erreichbar bin
ich nur noch mehr briefe starten kann
schreiben wir natürlich vor allem
diejenigen die die irgendwie motivierte
mit schreiben also dass das diesen
ganzen diese ganzen guten med oder hast
mir jetzt bekomme ich nicht mit
irgendwann kann auch haft klingt wie
kriegen sie aber ich habe das erlebt das
waren das ist dass allein die form des
papiers ein großer fehler ist
das ist eine höflichkeit leute sind
vielleicht menschen sind vielleicht
anderer meinung
aber allein die papierform die andere
rede sehr geehrter oder so erzeugt ein
mindestmaß an zivilisation oder für das
herbei und dann ist ja in ordnung dann
ist ja völlig in ordnung wenn ich mal
ein anderer meinung ist oder sagt das
sehe ich noch vollkommen anders oder
hier spenden sie oder hier irgendwie so
lange nämlich nicht beleidigt ist es
durch gespräche und das ist denn das ist
ja in ordnung aber wenn sie jetzt fragen
ob ich sie nach dem muslime gefragt
haben
ich glaube dass das heute meinen lesern
der anteil von muslimen höher als in der
gesamtbevölkerung liegt das war
sozusagen
[Gelächter]
sie sind ja selber aus sage ich jetzt
mal public intellectual auch in der
rolle so zusammen es tröstet das oder
sie werden mal gebeten und salbungsvolle
worte um einzuordnen um zu besänftigen
aber sie sind manchmal auch ein
störenfried wie für durch die
salbungsvollen worte sie gerne fragen ob
sie lieber mögen sind sie lieber ein
tröster oder sind sie lieber ein
störenfried also ich bin hoffentlich
keiner dass ich hoffe und ich bin nicht
dass also würde ich das so wäre würde
ich mich unwohl fühlen also das ist
jemand der literatur schafft sie wollen
nach reparatur ist ja muss ja oft
brechen muss er muss ja was was muss ja
widerstand erzeugen muss ja muss ja
dinge wie gehabt also das ist nicht die
aufgabe von literatur die primäre
überhaupt nicht meine ich konnte mich zu
trösten oder im gegenteil
also werde ich vater geworden oder etwas
anderes geworden
das ist das gibt es also nicht dass ich
das ablehne dieser funktion die muss
sich ergeben die tröstenden worte aber
das ist nicht die aufgabe dass das stift
gelassen da wäre es wäre mir peinlich
wenn ich dieses album warten würde
natürlich gibt es ein format also
gelegentlich werde ich gebeten eine
trauerrede zu halten und das ist ein
anderes format auch eine festrede und
bestimmte dinge da kann man eigentlich
auf dem auf dem laufenden das ist das
gute ein bestimmtes eine stimme formen
die man sich auch nicht respektiere
der trauerrede sagen auf den putz zu
hauen werden auch sehr komisch dass
künftig fahren waren oder es kommt
darauf an in welchem wetter was ist dir
angesprochene wäre es der adressat und
welchem zustand ist das nach dem mann
der am boden ist etwa nach der trauer
anschlägen stecken paris ist vielleicht
nicht der moment in dem viertel sondern
indem man versucht er zusammenzuhalten
und zusammenzuführen plan
wenn wir zurückgehen haben den anfang
wie blicken sie in die zukunft
also ehrlich gesagt blick in die zukunft
konkret das mache ich heute was mache
ich morgen also ich bin nicht jemand der
viel in die zukunft blickt also dass das
nicht sehr sehr weit weg hat das noch
sondern versuche sogar auch wirklich in
der gegenwart zu leben und und das so
gut ich kann nicht hier zu verhalten
sodass es halbwegs ähnliches für die
welt oder so das finde ich einen sehr
schönen schluss ich danke ihnen sehr
vielen dank dass sie hier waren navid
kermani jüdische nächste woche vertiefen
die ihr das thema der liebe zu gast bei
mir ist der bestseller autor allein
silber zu der uns in jena school of life
zu emotionaler intelligenz erziehen will
in seinem neuesten buch erklärt er uns
wie es mit der liebe weitergeht wenn die
schmetterlinge im bauch sich davon
gemacht haben haben sie eine
philosophische frage zuliebe dann
schreiben sie mir auf facebook oder an
philosophie hat srf punkt ch jetzt
gleich geht es hier weiter mit großer
literatur und zwar mit einem porträt
über den schriftsteller hans fallada der
die sorgen und nöte des kleinen mannes
vermessen hat wie keiner davor
vielen dank für ihr interesse und einen
schönen sonntag
[Musik]